ciao ragazzi e da un sacco che non ci
vediamo infatti volevo fare questo video
per aggiornarvi
spiegarvi un po e tranquillizzarvi in
tanti mi avete scritto inizia dove sei
finita vita non può i più vivi la vita
chiude il canale volevo rassicurarvi che
anche se sono sparita per un po tornerò
non vi preoccupate
e no non chiudo il canale non smetterò
di fare video non preoccupatevi
purtroppo sono stata molto male e
adesso però mi sto riprendendo come
potete vedere ho fatto varie visite
per questo appunto non ho pubblicato
video per un po di tempo in realtà era
già da un bel po di tempo che non stavo
proprio benissimo purtroppo dopo varie
visite
finalmente si è scoperto che cosa avevo
e ho una malattia cronica autoimmune
magari più avanti ve ne parlerò meglio
comunque che cosa significa che
purtroppo non c'è diciamo una cura al
momento magari nel futuro ci sarà spero
proprio di sì quindi in alcuni periodi
potrei non stare molto bene infatti ad
esempio quest'ultimo periodo non stavo
bene per questo non ho potuto pubblicare
questi video
per ora sto iniziando a sentirmi meglio
anche perché finalmente si è scoperto
che cos'è è appunto mi sto curando
bene più nello specifico in base a
questa malattia appunto è stato un
periodo un po difficile però sono
fiduciosa che ora le cose insomma spero
che andranno sempre meglio e io comunque
vi ringrazio tantissimo perché
nonostante la mia assenza voi avete
continuato a guardare il blu canale
continuato a commentare ogni giorno
sentivo comunque la vostra presenza e
questo mi ha aiutato tantissimo anche
nel mio processo insomma di di stare
meglio di sentirmi meglio
ho sentito comunque la vostra vicinanza
volevo però comunque fare questo video
per
rassicurarli che insomma non sparirà
completamente da youtube è solo che
appunto sono stato molto male adesso ma
adesso mi sto riprendendo e infatti tra
un pochino magari inizierete a vedere
qualche caricamento guadalcanal e
inizierò appunto cani a caricare un po
di video mano mano che sto meglio e io
spero tantissimo di stare sempre meglio
e
combatti essere sempre più forte di
stare sempre meglio è poter anzi
portarvi più video possibile però
purtroppo non posso sapere come andrà
quindi non so se in alcuni periodi
magari non starò benissimo e magari vi
avviserò e non ci saranno dei video per
quel periodo ma io spero che riuscirò a
stare bene il più a lungo possibile e
appunto di poter portare potervi portare
tanti video in cui ci saranno poi nei
prossimi mesi
più avanti ci saranno anche vari
cambiamenti nel canale cambieranno tante
cose niente questo è tutto ci tenevo
appunto ad aggiornarvi perché non tutti
hanno visto il post che feci varie
settimane fa in cui spiegavo che non
stavo molto bene quindi con questo video
spero che arrivi a tutti voi capiate il
perché mi sono assentato così io il
perchè potrebbe succedere ma come vi ho
detto io spero di stare sempre meglio e
che non ricapiti anche se non è una cosa
che posso controllare io abbiate ancora
un pochettino di pazienza perché davvero
vi assicuro che tra un po di mesi le
cose cambieranno spero tanto che varie
cose andranno molto molto meglio è però
appunto tanto di stare bene ma insomma
non vi preoccupate che non abbandono il
canale non chiudo il canale anzi è un
qualcosa che mi aiuta a fare video
creare video e distrarmi un momento mi
aiuta molto e infatti è quello che
voglio fare una volta che riprendo tutte
le forze e speranze di riprenderle al
110 per cento se non vedrete un video
magari ogni giorno non preoccupatevi
attivate la campanella e ogni volta che
caricherò non so quante volte ancora
perché non so appunto come andrà
riceverete la notifica così saprete che
ho caricato il video altrimenti qua su
youtube si sono anche tantissimi alti
creator su bravissimi che pubblicano
spesso ogni giorno quindi ci sono tante
cose da guardare e io comunque ci sarò
non so quanto frequentemente ma ci sarò
e poi tante cose cambieranno nei
prossimi mesi e niente questo è tutto
e spero che ora siete più tranquilli ora
che sapete la situazione e niente vi
abbraccio
un bacione enorme
ciao